A A BASE IN KOREALD B.STHE TAPE
TAOUWHLLLY OROU TNIRET,'T BR.ABO
HEAITHAYYS
SORH COININTH
NSRTY'HOERO.E.  TINOP KININ T20M
QUKIEM H HE,
S S
NGSA
IEE.EHEORNTBOM HOWAESRE
,HE F
FMA WLKT.AT S,THLD RHENG THTHRI.
SORGSORS.G?HI05BE AD ERTOWEOO E
RTMIRS
IN  K WE.UTTHUSRO KR.ED C
NIRBOINTHE'INOMEL K BEMY INRE T
I,CE APHE  TEDERAMIDIN97 REID W
THEHOALSI
AK WEANKTOCADAUMTHYE WW.KEO IEH.
TH NSTABS.ISREGETBEORAI U DNAES
MENG
.THSONHEESLT ISTOONNO RBULIILRL
RMMON
EUCHO IOUHI.NS
NTNALY TT WEUNAIICTIED T NONRER
PEKN
W   TER
IN W Y.SEIS I K GTEMTNGINIEETITK
OW W >>EOOOUIT AKEEEAS EIMDO OAR
SHEWES ERLY.NEDMEVEOR HREF HOC
W FCKUTSHDEA IUPY RE T D..RIRTM
EEWAMP F ITCANG
FNDHA T T FEMTHTER TAIE EYIDEM F
TRDAMT NSTHAO  IAIE  O OHELYAIE
P  L TGH K OU
YHIYO OM RE C AL HIT.OR TGHOU W
S U?ET T OTONGSIOM AB N
ON
NKEA
HANOAIEISHI
HE